good morning believe nation today's  message is believed over to you tech  nine I wake up every moon Express the BB  go we have to push for it if it's in  your heart because I'm from Kansas City  Missouri who would ever thought that you  can build an empire but if you put your  mind to it and push forward and push for  the key no matter if your family tell  you it's a hobby you need to do  something else to get money or whatever  man is like if you believe in and you  got to follow that dream your heart man  because if I didn't that wouldn't be in  any strange music to come to any  interview in because I followed my dream  after everybody knocked me down you have  to push forward if you believe in it you  will it's even it just gotta keep  pushing that's what I have to say I way  this pray so keep me going